[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wenn man bedenkt dass es zu den
wichtigsten Aufgaben des Parlaments
gehört über das Finanzgebaren von
Regierungen zu wachen kann man verstehen
warum die Oppositionsparteien im
Bundestag heute schonten vorgelegt wurde
dem Parlament ein 200 Milliarden
doppelwumms von dem aber noch keiner
genau sagen kann oder will wie das Geld
über die nächsten Jahre im Einzelnen
ausgegeben wird das liegt natürlich
gewissermaßen auch in der Natur der
Sache also einer Krise mit viel
unvorhersehbaren aber lädt dazu ein dass
Parlamentarier schimpfen ihn würde hier
die Katze im Sack präsentiert Peter
kurzbericht
keiner der Ressortminister keiner der
irgendwie zuständigen Minister ist heute
da das an sich ist schon ein Skandal der
doppelwumms halt durch den Bundestag und
trifft auf eine dreifache Lehrstelle der
Kanzler in Brüssel und auch Vize Harbeck
und vizepietze Lindner abwesend sie
hören die Kritik an ihrem
kreditkraftpaket nicht heute steht
einfach zu Entscheidung dass Sie von uns
ein Geldsack haben wollen gefüllt mit
200 Milliarden Euro und den wollen sie
sich dann in den Keller ihrer Regierung
stellen und dann wollen sie überlegen
und dann wollen sie überlegen was sie
mit dem Geld anfangen sie verweigern
hier heute die Grundvoraussetzung dass
wir die Bevölkerung und die Unternehmen
in diesem Land schützen können sie
halten ihre Rede daran auf sich zu
beschweren das Minister nicht da sind
ehrlicherweise es ist nicht die Stunde
der Regierung es ist die Stunde des
Parlaments jetzt hier heute der
Bundestag stimmte mit Mehrheit für die
200 Milliarden die die ampelregierung
braucht während deren Handlungsreisende
in Sachen Gas und Geld unterwegs waren
Robert Habeck und Christian Lindner in
Hannover bei den 16
ministerpräsidentinnen ein Tag für
Überzeugungsarbeit beiderseits wer zahlt
die Rechnungen was bremst die Gaspreise
am besten und vor allem wann greifen
Lösungen für die Leute im Land
ich glaube es wird von allen alles
versucht nichtsdestotrotz
Geschwindigkeit ist ein wichtiges
Momentum wenn es darum geht dass
Menschen einfach schlicht und ergreifend
Angst um bestimmte existenzielle Fragen
auch haben allen länderchefinnen und
Chefs hier geht es zu langsam und dass
der preisdeckel den die
gaspreiskommission der Bundesregierung
ausgearbeitet hat erst im März wirksam
werden soll versteht ihr schon mal gar
keiner die Kommission hat ja einen
Vorschlag gemacht mit der
Abschlagszahlung diesen diese Zeit
dazwischen Dezember Januar Februar zu
überbrücken wenn es noch mal berechnen
gibt die die Arbeit der Kommission in
Frage stellt dann dass wir uns damit
noch mal auseinander wir arbeiten mit
hohem Tempo daran dass bei den Menschen
und den Betrieben schon in diesem Jahr
beim Gas etwas sichtbar wird und dass
wir auch zu Beginn des nächsten Jahres
Versicherung an unser Land senden können
dass der Staat in dieser Krisenzeit mit
die finanziellen Belastungen abfedert
Anfang nächsten Jahres es gibt einen der
grantelt über mangelndes Tempo bei der
Krisenreaktion noch mehr als alle
anderen heute die Ampel Regierer an den
Ländern vorbei und Stelle nur die
Rechnung sagt Markus Söder früher mal
selbst Chef der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der MPK
davon ist in Bayern nur das Kennzeichen
für die Anfahrt geblieben
an der aktuelle Vorsitzende der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist uns aus
Hannover zugeschaltet Niedersachsens
Ministerpräsident Stefan weig guten
Abend Herr Wahl hallo Frau Slomka sie
sind ihre Kollegen die machen ja jetzt
ordentlich Druck das Ganze also die
gastbremse soll schon ab Januar kommen
nun hatte sich ja die
gas-bremsenkommission weil ich immer so
nennen darf ja was dabei gedacht die
sagen das ist technisch vorher nicht
möglich was bringt es also wenn man da
jetzt politisch Druck macht das
natürlich populär aber am Ende klappt es
dann technisch nicht also uns treibt
eher die Sorge dass wir mit einem hin
und her dann womöglich die Menschen noch
mehr verwirren als das jetzt schon der
Fall ist man muss sich das so vorstellen
es würde dann also im Dezember auf einen
Abschlag verzichtet werden eine
Entlastung im Januar im Februar würden
dann umso höhere Abschläge genommen
werden in vielen Fällen treten die
abschlagserhöhung erstmal im
Jahresanfang in Kraft aber im März soll
es dann wieder die Entlastung geben und
dieses Hin und Her das kann man
eigentlich glaube ich kaum vernünftig
kommunizieren sie merken ja schon wie
viel Zeit ich dafür brauche
und deswegen müssen wir uns wirklich
anstrengen für einen Fahrt zu sorgen der
vom Dezember beginnend an kontinuierlich
auch für Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nachvollziehbar ist der Dezember
Abschlag von dem sie gerade Sprachen der
sich ja auf frühere verbreche und
konzentriert aber die Leute nicht
anfangen wie blöd irgendwie jetzt Gas zu
verwenden damit der Abschlag höher wird
der ist ja als Entlastung gedacht also
damit man das ganze so ein bisschen
übersteht man sie wirklich dass das die
Menschen jetzt in so eine wahnsinnige
Verwirrung wirft wenn Sie wissen okay
und ab März gibt es dieses Kontingent ja
also ich glaube dass die meisten sehr
gerne zur Kenntnis nehmen dass im
Dezember weniger bezahlen müssen aber
dann umso mehr sich fragen warum muss
ich denn dann im Januar Februar umso
mehr zahlen und dass sie dann im März
wieder weniger zahlen das ist wirklich
schwer zu erklären und wir glauben auch
dass es bessere Möglichkeiten gibt
wird denn dabei dann trotzdem gesichert
weil sie hat mir zum Beispiel den
Vorschlag dass die Energieunternehmen
jetzt freiwillig auf Preiserhöhungen
verzichten bleibt dann trotzdem
gesichert das warum sich Ökonomen so
Sorgen machen dass man trotzdem immer
noch sagt Leute wir tun zwar alles um
das abzufedern aber es muss auch
wirklich Gas gespart werden und diese
spar-anreize dass die nicht verloren
gehen doch da bin ich absolut überzeugt
nicht umsonst hat die Kommission ja und
ich finde richtigerweise gesagt ja wir
können über 80 Prozent gewissermaßen
garantierte Preise reden aber für 20
Prozent muss jeder selber gerade stehen
und bei den hohen Preisen die derzeit
einfach geltend gemacht werden da machen
diese 20 Prozent schon genug aus dass
jeder von uns auf sich aufgerufen fühlen
sollte so gut wie möglich zu sparen im
Interesse nicht nur der Gasversorgung
sondern vor allen Dingen auch im
Interesse des eigenen Geldbeutels
Stichwort Geldbeutel das ganze muss ja
auch finanziert werden sind sie dafür
dass die Länder weil sie eben noch nicht
wissen was alles so aus sie zukommt dann
von der schuldenpreis Schuldenbremse im
nächsten Jahr befreit werden
ja ob ich dafür bin es ist gar nicht die
richtige Fragestellung jedenfalls für
mich nicht sondern in den fast allen
Ländern und sagen wir wir werden gar
nicht drumherum kommen das hängt mit
folgendem zusammen wir haben schon
gemeinsam mit den Kommunen eine Mehrheit
der ersten beiden entlastungsprogramme
finanziert auch beim dritten
entlastungsprogramm das war dieses 65
milliardenprogramm sind wir mit einem
ganz hohen Anteil dabei und in fast
allen Ländern ist es so dass wir sagen
aus unserem Bordmitteln heraus werden
wir das nicht finanzieren können und
dafür sieht die Schuldenbremse ja auch
eine spezielle Klausel vor also wir
bewegen uns innerhalb der Schuldenbremse
wenn wir sagen in einer solchen
Notsituation da werden wir leider auch
Kredite aufnehmen müssen keiner von uns
würde das gerne tun das komische ist
dass die Bundesbank die Finanzsituation
der Länder so ganz anders einschätzt die
sagt die Länder stehen eigentlich
ziemlich gut da hatten hohe
steuereinnahmenüberschüsse Reserven
haben viel weniger an Sachen Ukraine
Krieg und Pandemie gezahlt als der Bund
und die könnten sich eigentlich jetzt
ganz gut an der Finanzierung beteiligen
wir kommen dann unterschiedliche
Wahrnehmungen Zustande vielleicht
deswegen weil das Haushaltsjahr 2022
tatsächlich eigentlich für die Länder
ganz gut läuft das hängt damit zusammen
dass die Preiskrise ja erst im zweiten
Halbjahr so richtig begonnen hat aber
wir das ganze Jahr hinweg wirklich gute
Steuereinnahmen hatten hängt auch damit
zusammen dass der Staat natürlich in
Zeiten der Inflation automatisch auch
höhere Steuereinnahmen hat aber wenn wir
aufs nächste Jahr gucken da sehen wir
wirklich deutlich mehr Ausgaben wir
haben das ganze Jahr über hohe
Energiepreise wir werden deutliche
Mindereinnahmen haben einfach durch die
entlastungsprogramme von denen ich
gesprochen habe und das macht dann
wirklich ein ganz großen Unterschied und
deswegen ändern sich bei uns in den
Haushalten dann auch wirklich die
Vorzeichen und haben sie mit dem
Bundeskanzler über dieses Thema
schuldenpreis Schuldenbremse gesprochen
ja natürlich das sind ja liegt ja auf
der Hand denn wenn der Bund möchte dass
die Länder auch ihren Anteil beitragen
und wir da auch nicht prinzipiell nein
sagen
müssen wir auch über die Frage reden wie
kommen wir eigentlich dazu und dann
müssen wir auch beispielsweise eine
gemeinsame Einschätzung der Situation
haben ich frage halt weil
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner ja
eigentlich wild entschlossen ist ab 2023
die Schuldenbremse wieder einzuhalten ja
also ob der Bund sie einhalten kann oder
nicht das will ich gar nicht bewerten
das kann mit Sicherheit der
Bundesfinanzminister besser als ich aber
was ganz wichtig ist dass wir gemeinsam
von einer Visum Grundgesetz heißt
außergewöhnlichen Notsituationen
ausgehen das ist ja die Voraussetzung
dafür dass man letzten Endes auch
Kredite aufnehmen kann noch einmal das
machen wir ja nicht weil wir Freude an
der Kreditaufnahme haben sondern weil
wir sehen dass wir in einer Situation
sind wo wir so handeln müssen wann
hätten wir denn eine Notlage wenn ich
jetzt
danke für das Gespräch sehr gerne
tschüss
das Interview haben wir vor einer Stunde
geführt in Europa hat der 200 Milliarden
doppelwumms ja für viel Ärger gesorgt
Tenor erst bringen sich die Deutschen
mit ihren russland-geschäften selbst in
die Bredouille und jetzt stechen Sie mit
ihrer Finanzkraft auch noch alle anderen
aus nach dem Willen vieler EU-Länder
angeführt von Frankreich bräuchte
Deutschland auch gar keine nationale
gaspreisbremse wenn ein gemeinsamer
europäischer Gaspreis Deckel eingeführt
wurde daran glaubt die Bundesregierung
allerdings nicht Scholz hat sich beim
Gipfel in Brüssel mit Händen und Füßen
gegen die Vorschläge von macron und
anderen gewehrt wie sie an der
europäischen gasbörse eingreifen wollen
haben sie bisher aber auch noch nicht
gesagt Guna Krüger berichtet
Europas Fieberkurve folgt gerade der des
Gaspreises darum will eine Mehrheit von
Europas Politikern am größten Markt dem
TTF die stärksten Schübe kühlen Info AVO
wir brauchen sozusagen ein ehrlicheres
Thermometer und wir wollen einen
Mechanismus einführen um die tägliche
Spekulation auf den Märkten zu stoppen
doch vorerst bleibt es bei einem
Prüfauftrag für einen Preiskorridor
einen Deckel wird es nicht geben
andernfalls nehmen die tankerkurs auf
Asien befürchtet der Kanzler doch seine
Alleingänge beim Gaseinkauf seinen
doppelwumms haben sie in Brüssel wohl
notiert Scholz ist isoliert muss
Solidarität zeigen Gasspeicher will nun
auch er zum Teil gemeinsam füllen
private Unternehmen können sich auf
freiwilliger Basis für Einkäufe
zusammenschließen dass ein großer
Fortschritt weil bisher das
Wettbewerbsrecht gegen solche
Aktivitäten steht Frage ein Experten was
also bringen die Gipfelbeschlüsse dem
Verbraucher
es sind Angebot und Nachfrage die die
Preise bestimmen diese Maßnahmen die
jetzt beschlossen wurden können auch
daran nichts ändern die können sozusagen
Volatilität und Nervosität aus Markt
nehmen aber auf Dauer hilft nur Gas
sparen oder Gas importieren
Europas andere Abhängigkeit die von
China war heute Gipfel Thema den Verkauf
kritischer Infrastruktur wie 2016 den
griechischen Hafen Piräus sehen viele
rückblickend als Fehler
wir dachten wir müssten die Finanzen
Regeln und sahen Europa als einen
Supermarkt für alle
das klingt wie ein Vorwurf denn in
Hamburg will nun der gleiche
Staatskonzern aus China bei einem
Terminal einsteigen und Scholz sagt
nicht nein im November will er zudem
nach Peking Reisen mit
Wirtschaftsdelegation das wird so
gemacht das war bisher immer so dass da
welche dabei waren
deshalb müsste man die Frage warum wohl
beantworten wenn man es nicht tut ist
mein Gefühl
doch die zeitenwände verlangt auf alte
Fragen neue Antworten dass ein weiter so
nicht ausreicht auch das Gefühl gibt es
tja zum Hamburger Hafen sagte Olaf
Scholz heute bringt es noch da seit noch
nichts entschieden und Fräulein Brüssel
bahnt sich da der nächste Konflikt an in
der EU
also das könnte schon sein diese Hafen
oder hafenbeteiligung der Chinesen hat
doch eine hohe Symbolkraft weil er eben
für die Abhängigkeit Europas von der
chinesischen Wirtschaft steht und vor
allem für die Abhängigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft und man wundert sich ein
bisschen dass man die jetzt noch in
diesen schwierigen Zeiten noch stärker
erhöhen will und so ist eben auch die
Kritik vom französischen Präsidenten
macron zu verstehen der gesagt hat das
war naive der Vergangenheit was er so
viel heißt Olaf Scholz macht nicht noch
mal etwas naives insgesamt hat die
Europäische Union gestern und heute auch
noch mal über China nachgedacht versucht
eine Strategie zu entwickeln aber sie
ist hier in einer Falle auf der einen
Seite braucht Europa die chinesische
Wirtschaft um sein eigenes
wohlstandsmodell aufrecht zu halten auf
der anderen Seite wächst immer mehr die
Kluft zwischen den Werten Systemen China
wird immer mehr eine dunkle Diktatur und
da ist dann dieses Dilemma zwischen
wirtschaftlicher Notwendigkeit und
moralische Ablehnung und da ist das
Augenmerk eben auch sehr ein groß auf
Deutschland weil das besonders abhängig
von China ist also wie gesagt da wird es
wohl in Zukunft noch heftige
Diskussionen geben Dankeschön Herr
Brüssel auf Roller
beim EU-Gipfel heute ging es natürlich
auch um die Ukraine mit neuen
Hilfszusagen seitens der Europäer und
welche anderen aktuellen Entwicklungen
ist in diesem Krieg jetzt gibt damit
geht es bei dir jetzt weiter Heinz heute
gab es ein Telefonat zwischen
US-Verteidigungsminister Austin und
seinem russischen Kollegen Schuhe von
russischer Seite hieß es ist sein
aktuelle Fragen der internationalen
Sicherheit einschließlich der Lage in
der Ukraine erörtert worden das Pentagon
teilte mit Austin habe die Bedeutung
einer Beibehaltung von
Kommunikationswegen inmitten des
andauernden Krieges gegen die Ukraine
hervorgehoben
in diesen Krieg wird seit Tagen massiv
die Energieinfrastruktur der Ukraine
angegriffen und jetzt wirft Präsident
selensky Russland vor einen
staudammtermin zu haben
silenski warnte vor einer Katastrophe
großen Ausmaßes sollte der Damm des
Wasserkraftwerkes kahovka im Süden des
Landes brechend könnte unter anderem die
Stadt herson überflutet werden Moskau
weist den Vorwurf zurück
der Bundestag hat eine Verlängerung des
Bundeswehreinsatzes im Irak beschlossen
um ein Jahr bis Ende Oktober 2023
vorgesehen ist die Entsendung von bis zu
500 Bundeswehrsoldaten es geht um eine
weitere Beteiligung am Einsatz gegen die
terrormiliz is und die Ausbildung
irakischer Streit und Sicherheitskräfte
in Italien soll die Vorsitzende der
ultrarechten fratellit Italia Georgia
Meloni neue Ministerpräsidentin werden
Staatspräsident materella gab ihr am
Abend den Auftrag zur Bildung einer
neuen Regierung gemeinsam mit ihrem
Kabinett soll sie morgen vereidigt
werden mit den fratelli wird unter
anderem die Forza Italia um Silvio
Berlusconi und Matthäus albinis
rechtspopulistische Liga regieren
nach dem Rückzug von Premierministerin
löst Trust mehren sich in der britischen
Regierung die Stimmen für Boris Johnson
als Nachfolger so verwies
Verteidigungsminister Wallace darauf
dass Johnson die konservativen Tories
2019 zum Wahlsieg geführt habe als
weitere aussichtsreiche Kandidaten
gelten der frühere Finanzminister Richie
sunak und die Ministerin für
parlamentsfragen Penny mordent die
bislang als einzige ihre Kandidatur
offiziell bekannt gegeben hat
in fünf Bundesländern war heute letzter
Schultag vor den Herbstferien Zeitung zu
verschnaufen und dann mal sehen wie es
weitergeht wenn alle in die Wintermonate
zurückkehren die Lehrerverbände warnen
vor mehr Unterrichtsausfall durch
corona-infektionen denn auch wenn nicht
mehr getestet wird wenn Lehrkörper krank
flach liegen können sie halt nicht
unterrichten hinzu kommt der generelle
Lehrermangel wie eklatant das zum
Beispiel in Berlin ist beschreibt
Stefanie gargosch
lernen für das Leben bei Eleonore stockt
das bereits in der Grundschule schreiben
top Mathe schwierig sie bräuchte
Förderung diese kann ihre Schule in
Berlin aber nicht mehr anbieten
Lehrermangel nun wiederholt Eleonore die
zweite Klasse und die Mutter hilft wo es
geht
ist ungeschickt das System findest der
Stadt nicht machen kann und
helfen also nicht helfen möchte muss ich
als Mutter
kürzer treten dafür weniger leisten
jeder schon ich bin kein Pädagoge und
kannst dem Kind nicht so erklären wie
ein Lehrer neben dem Lehrpersonal fehlen
in Berlin auch Schulplätze vor allem an
den Grundschulen inzwischen wird zwar
gebaut doch zu spät für die jetzigen
Schülerinnen und Schüler die Folge die
Klassen werden größer
also die Situation was Personal betrifft
und was auch den baulichen Zustand der
Schulen bzw den schulplatzbedarf
betrifft hat sich das verschlechtert in
den letzten Jahren kontinuierlich wir
haben deutlichen Fehlbedarf an Plätzen
der sich in Berlin mittlerweile auf
20.000 summiert das sind jetzt nicht
Schülerinnen und Schüler die irgendwo
auf der Straße stehen die sind schon in
den Schulgebäuden untergebracht aber die
sind halt wirklich voll gequetscht
unklar wer zudem einen neuen Schulen
unterrichten soll bundesweit fielen
Zehntausende von Lehrerinnen und Lehrern
gleichzeitig steigen die Schülerzahlen
weiter an besonders in den großen
Städten verfehlte Bildungspolitik die
Prognosen der wachsenden Schüler zahlen
sollte der Kultusministerkonferenz kurz
KMK seit Jahren bekannt gewesen sein
2023 wird Berlins Bildungssenatorin der
KMK vorstehen warum nicht früher
gehandelt wurde
dieses Problem das hat sich ja schon
länger gezeigt da hätte man hingucken
müssen ja ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht aber man
denkt manchmal nur in Legislaturperioden
möglicherweise und jetzt ist das Problem
aber so ernst es ist ja ein Problem ein
Problem wie geht es mit unserem Land
weiter und wie können wir unseren
Wohlstand auch behalten größere Klassen
Mehrbelastung des Lehrpersonals
stundenausfälle der lehrerberufe dadurch
nicht attraktiver die jungen Menschen
die jetzt in der Schule sind und mit all
den Problematiken die im täglichen
Schulleben sind konfrontiert werden die
müssen sich ja eigentlich für den Beruf
entscheiden also stehen hier vor der
Herausforderung den Beruf auch wieder
attraktiv zu machen das ist eine enorme
Herausforderung weil wir gleichzeitig in
den Beruf arbeiten und die Belastung
sehen und über die Belastung müssen wir
ja sprechen weil die auch dadurch
entsteht das war zu wenig Lehrer haben
kinder sind die Zukunft ihre Bildung für
unsere Gesellschaft wertvolles Gut im
Moment aber verwalten die Schulen immer
stärker den Mangel
stand jetzt noch mal Heinz mit einem
anderen Zukunftsthema Wasserstoff gilt
als eine Energieträger der Zukunft wie
die Lieferung und dann die Verwendung
konkret aussehen kann dazu gibt es in
Hamburg einen Testlauf weil realer heute
war sozusagen offizielle
materialübergabe genau beim
kupferhersteller Aurubis dort soll der
Wasserstoff jetzt testweise mal
eingesetzt werden er kommt aus den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten und von
dort sollen künftig mehr
wasserstoffprodukte geliefert werden was
steckt dahinter Deutschland will
unabhängig werden von russischer Energie
außerdem soll Wasserstoff sozusagen die
grüne Alternative zu erdgaswerden da
dreht Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
symbolisch den Gashahn auf Startschuss
für einen Testlauf mit den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten der erste Tank ist
gefüllt mit Ammoniak einem Stoff der als
ideales Transportmittel für Wasserstoff
gilt Aurubis will es acht Wochen lang
zur Herstellung von Kupferdraht ein
müssen als Beigabe zum herkömmlichen Gas
Wasserstoff und Ammoniak sollen
langfristig die Klimabilanz Deutschlands
verbessern der Wasserstoff aus den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten ist
sogenannter blauer Wasserstoff er wurde
mit Erdgas hergestellt dabei
entstehendes CO2 wird gespeichert oder
weiter verwendet Umweltschützer halten
den blauen Wasserstoff für eine
Mogelpackung weil dafür enorme Mengen
von Erdgas nötig sind wirklich grün sind
Wasserstoff und Ammoniak tatsächlich nur
wenn sie mit erneuerbaren Energien
hergestellt wurden bis dafür aber genug
Kapazitäten da sind kann es noch Jahre
dauern
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball-Bundesliga
eine Entschuldigung wir haben zuerst
noch eine corona-meldung zur
corona-situation in Deutschland nach
wochenlangem Anstieg deuten die
offiziell gemeldeten Infektionszahlen
wieder auf etwas Entspannung hin das
Robert-Koch-Institut gab die bundesweite
7 Tage Inzidenz heute mit
644,5 an und damit niedriger als am
Vortag und in der Vorwoche allerdings
gehen Experten seit einiger Zeit von
einer hohen Zahl von so nicht erfassten
Fällen aus vor allem weil nicht alle
infizierten einem PCR-Test machen lassen
aber nur positive PCR-Tests in der
Statistik zählen
jetzt das Ergebnis aus der
Fußball-Bundesliga Mainz hat er am Abend
Köln zu Gast und gerade ist das Spiel zu
Ende gegangen fünf zu null für Mainz
nach zwei Fachtagen hat die Frankfurter
Buchmesse seit heute für das breite
Lesepublikum geöffnet bei der
weltgrößten Bücherschau präsentieren bis
Sonntag 4.000 Aussteller aus 95 Ländern
ihre Neuerscheinungen eine Schwerpunkt
haben die Messemacher auf die Ukraine
gelegt denn am Sonntag wird der
Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchhandels
an Serie shardan verliehen eine der
bedeutendsten Schriftsteller des Landes
dieser Freitag ist wieder ein
Politbarometer Freitag die
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen hat wieder das
Meinungsbild zu vielen aktuellen Themen
abgefragt unter anderem zu den
persönlichen wirtschaftlichen
Erwartungen zur Atomkraft Frage und zur
Performance der ampelkoalitionäre die
Ergebnisse präsentiert ihn jetzt
Matthias fornos
[Musik]
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer eine Koalition auf
Augenhöhe versprach Olaf Scholz kurz
bevor er Kanzler wurde doch was wenn bei
der Ampel grün und gelb besonders
glänzen wollen dann schaltet der Chef
doch mal auf rot und sagt Stopp bis
hierher und nicht weiter
insgesamt wird die Arbeit der Regierung
zurückhaltend positiv bewertet und die
der einzelnen Parteien
52% sagen dass die SPD ihre Arbeit in
der Regierung eher gutmache 38 Prozent
sehen das nicht so die Leistung der
Grünen bewährten 49 Prozent als gut 43
Prozent als eher schlecht dass die FDP
ihre Sache gutmacher sagen hingegen 36
Prozent
53% meinen sie regiere eher schlecht
das kanzlerbuster kam an in der Krise
werden pragmatische Kompromisse
honoriert das grün-gelbe Gezerre um die
Atomkraft wurde vor allem als
ideologischer Streit wahrgenommen und
kostet beide Ansehen in der Sache aber
teilt die Mehrheit die Position der FDP
nur acht Prozent fenten ist gut wenn die
drei verbliebenen Atomkraftwerke ab
Januar abgeschaltet würden für die
jetzige Lösung sie bis Mitte April
weiter zu betreiben sind 36 Prozent 55
Prozent hielten es für sinnvoll sie noch
länger laufen zu lassen
die akw-frage ist für die meisten wohl
nicht eines der wichtigsten Probleme
wenn am nächsten Sonntag Bundestagswahl
wäre käme die SPD auf 19 Prozent plus
eins
cdu/csu-28 ebenfalls eins hoch die
Grünen -1 21 Prozent die
fdp6-1 die AFD 15 einen Punkt rauf die
Linke unverändert 5%
. damit hätte die Ampel erstmals keine
Mehrheit mehr erreichen würde es dagegen
für eine Koalition aus schwarz und grün
schauen wir auf unsere Top Ten also die
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung auf der Skala von
+5 bis -5 haben sich nach Abstürzen in
den letzten Umfragen fast alle wieder
verbessert
Alice Weidel ist Schlusslicht -2,7 etwas
besser
vorletzte Sahra Wagenknecht minus 0,9
deutlich besser Friedrich Merz -0,2
etwas besser Christian Lindner -0,1
davor Markus Söder 0,0 verbessert Karl
Lauterbach 0,3 deutlich besser Cem
Özdemir 0,6 etwas besser auf dem dritten
Platz Robert Habeck 0,8 Annalena
baerbock II 0,9 und ganz knapp vorn Olaf
Scholz auch 0,9 alle drei sehr viel
besser als beim letzten Mal
die Mehrheit der Deutschen findet dass
die Bundesregierung zu wenig tut um die
Bürger zu entlasten trotzdem sehen die
meisten ihre persönliche wirtschaftliche
Situation zur Zeit noch positiv
54 Prozent sagen meine wirtschaftliche
Situation ist gut 36 Prozent sehen es
teils teils und neun Prozent bewerten
ihre Lager als schlecht der Ausblick
aber ist pessimistisch nur neun Prozent
erwarten dass sie in einem Jahr besser
gestellt sein werden 46 Prozent gehen
davon aus dass ihre Lage gleich bleibt
und 43% befürchten dass sie ihre eigene
wirtschaftliche Situation verschlechtert
wird
das Schulden finanzierte 200 Milliarden
Paket das Bürger und Unternehmen
entlasten soll ging zwar heute durch den
Bundestag wer aber wie vom sogenannten
doppelwurms profitieren wird ist noch
ziemlich unklar außerdem
ärgert die gigantische Geldschwemme
unsere europäischen Nachbarn die sich so
große rettungsspritzen nicht leisten
können
ist der Vorwurf gerechtfertigt dass
durch das 200 Milliarden Paket deutsche
Unternehmen einen Wettbewerbsvorteil in
der EU bekommen
26% finden ja 65 Prozent nein
zum Schluss noch ein Blick nach China
das global immer mächtiger mitmischt
etwa jeder zweite Befragte geht davon
aus dass von dem autokratischen
Riesenreich eine große oder sogar sehr
große Bedrohung für die westlichen
Demokratien ausgeht
das Deutschland von China wirtschaftlich
unabhängiger wird
84% wichtig 13 Prozent sehen da keinen
Handlungsbedarf
Anfang November würde Kanzler Scholz
nach Peking Reisen an seiner Seite viele
Unternehmer wie umgehen mit der
antidemokratischen Weltmacht auf
Expansionskurs auch Deutschland wird
diese Frage für sich beantworten müssen
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF textab Seite 165 in
der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF heute.de
wie die repräsentativen Umfragen der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen zustande kommen
Informationen zur Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
politbarometer.df.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am
11 November hier folgt jetzt das Wetter
danach geht es weiter mit der heute show
viel Spaß dabei und einen schönen Abend
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht und morgen
verstärkt sich der Regen im Süden noch
einmal das sind keine riesigen Mengen
aber lokal können in kräftigen Gewittern
oder auch im Südschwarzwald über 30
Liter pro Quadratmeter bis morgen Abend
fallen verbreitet sind das um die 10
Liter pro Quadratmeter anders ist das im
Norden da gibt es nur einzelne Schauer
mit bis 5 Liter pro Quadratmeter wo
kommt das ganze her nun wir haben ein
Sturmtief über Irland und den britischen
Inseln das hier für turbulente Zeiten
sorgt und das schickt uns jetzt wieder
ein kleines Randtief das auch die Alpen
erfasst und hier in der Höhe einigen
Schnee bringt so also bei uns in der
Nacht gibt es mit diesen eingelagerten
Gewittern dann schon im Südschwarzwald
kräftige Regenfälle im Verlauf der Nacht
zieht das Ganze nach Osten ab im
Nordosten lassen letzte Schauer und
Gewitter nach dann wird es trocken
örtlich in der feuchten Luft neblig
meist bleibt es aber bewölkt so dass die
Temperaturen nur selten in den
einstelligen Bereich sinken meist sinken
sie auf 10 bis 10 Grad morgen gibt es
verbreitet sehr milde 18 bis 22 Grad im
Südosten bleiben wir teils bei 15 Grad
denn hier ist es vormittags auch
regnerisch vom Bodensee bis zum
Erzgebirge nachmittags zieht das aber ab
es verbleiben letzte Schauer auch im
Norden sind einzelne Schauer unterwegs
meist heitert es am Nachmittag aber auf
sonntags dreht der Wind auf Süd dann
sind im Südwesten sogar bis 23 Grad drin
nachmittags einzelne Schauer im Westen
am Montag kommt mit der neuen Woche ein
neues Tief mit stärkerem Wind mehr
Schauern eingelagerten Gewittern und
auch in der neuen Woche geht es sehr
mild weiter tschüss